democrats that's right who's opposed to
it republican republican
republicans in my opinion are just i'm
it's trash
okay donald trump is very different and
i think most trump supporters recognize
that many of these republicans are just
crony establishment but hold on hold on
at least they at at least
they're doing very little and they're
kind of ineffectual
well you got you got something to say
about republicans doing something else
um i have
i wanted to finish my point by
specifically saying there's too many
too many people profiting off of these
lockdowns
off of these restrictions for them to
end anytime soon so we have to
understand there's another factor here
that that we have to understand that
that that when it comes to the
billionaires when it comes to the
establishment when it comes to the
ruling class they are getting way too
many benefits
from this lockdown for it to do the
vaccine company is going to make
tons of money visor is set to make a lot
of money but we have
billions we also have to understand this
is a company that literally
just came out yesterday and they said
that quote this is the chairman of
pfizer we're not sure if someone can
transmit the virus
if they take the back seat and and this
is you know what's the same company
because they want everyone to take it
because well everybody might be
vaccinated right
you could still get sick again he's
saying there's no hurt immunity with the
vaccine that's what he's saying
which means everybody must get it or he
doesn't know if there is yeah
which means everybody must get it so
somebody google this google this
somebody super chatted saying one of the
proposals going through right now is
that the stimulus will only go to those
who get vaccinated whoa what
there are proposals by some democrats
saying that if you want to receive the
new stimulus checks
there is some writings in some of the
legislation it hasn't passed but it's
being proposed and it's being talked
about and it wouldn't surprise me
and there will be a certificate that
people will be getting
after getting this vaccine which was
officially announced today as well but
we have to understand here pfizer
i think you're right i think he's making
that statement to make sure more people
have this general idea that they need
this thing but when it comes to pfizer
one they're not facing any liability
surrounding this
but this is a company that paid out
close to
five billion dollars since 2000
in damages and fines to individuals to
organizations and to governments for
corruption
this time they can't do that and listen
listen
i know a lot of people want to make it
about the vaccine but this is about
transfer of wealth
what they want is we want carte blanche
for the government to transfer taxpayer
dollars to us with zero liability and
that's what they are getting
not just them but these other companies
too but let's and then i just want to go
off on a little tangent here because
this is going to be the largest
vaccine program that the united states
has ever had and has ever dealt with and
i think it's also important to look back
in history
especially in american history at the
latest
vaccine program that was the largest
before this one and it was the 1976
swine flu the h1n1 vaccine that 25
percent of americans got
in a 10-month span this was because one
u.s soldier at fort dix in new jersey
came down with the h1n1 swine flu and
the government then decided to have a
full-scale response everyone's going to
get a vaccine we're going to fast
track it we're going to move forward
we're going to make sure that no one
gets this h1n1 that we found at fort dix
new jersey with this one u.s soldier
dying
what happened with this vaccine program
it was
very unnecessary because what year was
it
1976 because the virus h1n1
never left fort dix no one else was
affected by this
but they still vaccinated 25
of americans in a 10-month span and
the vaccine was found to have links with
galen
barine syndrome which has injured
yes which is i'm saying that wrong has
injured a large number of individuals
all of it
totally unnecessary totally made up
because a politician
said he's going to help everyone said
he's going to fix everything
we've got we got we got the official
source i've got discover
discover magazine certified news guard
and there's a quote
the swine flu program was marred by a
series of logistical problems ranging
from the production of the wrong vaccine
strain
to a confrontation over liability
protection to a temporal connection of
the vaccine and a cluster of deaths
among the elderly population in
pittsburgh
sound familiar yes exactly the most
damning charge against the vaccination
program was that the shots were
correlated with an
increase in the number of patients
diagnosed with an obscure neurological
disease
known as gelane bar syndrome is that
pronounced guillain-barre there you go
you see he can't pronounce it neither
can i
so look this was the largest vaccine
program in the united states and now
we're about to go through another one
i'm not saying that there's any
correlation or any mixes extremely
different circumstances
but it's important to understand here
that there is history with the united
states
doing okay human experience
is it fair to say that i think we've
made substantive developments in the 44
years
since 1976 right there have been many
important developments with
big pharma that has helped a lot of
people there's no denying that
but when it comes to holding this
industry accountable i think there needs
to be a lot more oversight a lot more
scrutiny and a little bit more
skepticism because there isn't
now is it fair to label it all
it's all good um i would i'm gonna show
you an article
go ahead from market watch wall street
and finance workers could get coveted
vaccines before most americans yes
that doesn't prove anything again no no
no no no no no no no no
wait wait go go go if if you think
there's some risk here don't worry
they're giving it to wall street
financiers first
i say give it to the government
officials first i think that would solve
all of our problems
look i really do mean it when i say i'm
not obama
bush and some other person are lined up
to get the vaccine it's clinton
bill clinton the guy who said he didn't
have relations with that woman
barack obama who drank the water from
flint right
and the guy who told us that those
weapons of mass destruction
are now going to tell me that they're
taking this shot that we don't know what
it is
again one thing that we have to
understand here is again we can't just
paint everything black and white we
can't just say everything's good and bad
there is important middle ground there
is gray zones that we need to look into
that we need to consider
but i do truly believe that we are aware
of all the positive sides but not of the
negative sides and people need to be
aware the united
states has a long history of going after
human beings that didn't know what was
happening and experimenting with them
with medical procedures i could list off
your future i have here
and i don't know but okay experiment
can i get into this list i mean we have
the cia lsd experiments that led
to people dying that was kind of the
tostiga experiments
that happened to hundreds of individuals
and as they were dying as they became
blind as they became insane
because of syphilis that was given to
them by
a u.s government grant they decided not
to treat it and this was all funded by
u.s taxpayers
in 1953 through 1954 and 1963 to 1965
st louis was literally sprayed with
radioactive
particles in order to conduct a military
test
agent orange in vietnam depleted uranium
in iraq
the 1948 operation sea spray project
again i could keep going on and on
there are so many instances where the us
government literally
unsuspecting citizens just said we're
just going to
test you with all this different stuff
there's going to be a lot of negative
consequences but we're going to cover it
up my mom was telling me this is a
philosophical question here go ahead
it's it's deontological versus
utilitarian
do you think the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few it depends
on the situation
that's very hard to say that's a very
brilliant generalized statement quote
from what star trek ii i think was i
don't know
if the many are destroying everything
then no
so if so the the needs of them right so
you're so that's exactly the mentality
not when it comes to
security or saving the situation then
yes unsuspecting american citizens and
testing them with
uh ddt and syphilis no
i'm saying right now let's say that uh
there is
a a you know an increase in certain
syndromes
like uh how do you pronounce it again
genre
guillain-barre just say it really
quickly sometimes yeah it's great your
mispronounced it glenn beret so so one
of the arguments when there was that big
remember that movie
vaxxed came out or whatever yes i
actually went to uh the cdc and had a
big conversation with a lot of people
there
and they were very much like this is
ridiculous and one of the things that i
said that
said was they were like i want you to
think about something let's say that one
in 300 000 people do develop
a very severe negative symptom now when
they do
it's not always like permanent paralysis
it could just be
a like a minor thing right if it does
is it worth saving the lives of three
million people if it means that 30
will end up getting some kind of
negative impact it's like the questions
we have to ask are very difficult
yes because we recognize that we want to
maximize good
we want to do the right by most people
but it means when you're looking at
people like numbers
you'll see that they're going to be
people who suffer but what do you do
help no one
no you're honest you don't lie to people
you tell them the risks that are
involved
with getting this experimental vaccine
that history and medical science has
never seen before you tell the people
what they're getting themselves into
and i was going to ask you the same cdc
that's tied in with special interest
the same cdc that keeps changing their
official point of view and stance on the
covid virus everything is about
everything there's a balance
there is look there is a balance we
deserve a lot
more truth we deserve a lot more
accountability we deserve a lot more
information and we're not getting it
we're getting lies by government
officials who think they're better and
more important and could tell us and
lecture us
that we don't need masks when they work
when they want to know there's two kinds
of people right now there are two kinds
of people
one that says i trust the government
wholeheartedly no matter what
that's insane and the other that say i
never trust the government at all
but in between is the real gradient of
people who say
there are certain things i trust in
certain things i don't certainly people
would say i trust the troops
right um depends on what's they're
absolutely you're in afghanistan
and if you're not i'm talking about
american citizens do you trust the
government luke hell no
but you would you trust a a a service
man who said it depends i don't know him
if
if there was a guy any and you pull up
in your car and he stops and says
there's a raging wildfire ahead please
don't go down that way we're trying to
get it secure we're saving lives
would you trust them it depends on the
circumstance and situation i would
actually see
the fact check it out smoke coming up
and they said stop stop stop if you go
there you'll die we can't let you do
this
am i escaping other government agents
now to throw me into female camps listen
is he wearing a badge what i'm saying is
at the end of the day
everybody chooses who and what they
trust of course and there are some
people that say to all those things
yes they happened because the government
in the united states has done horrifying
things and many on the left protest a
lot of these things
but not anymore protesting right it goes
back and forth
yeah well i never learned about it in
school or anything i had to find out
what
talks about how the us government treats
its citizens like
just gerbils that they could do whatever
they want with another issue to really
consider and to really talk about is
gain of
function data when we're looking at the
studies that happen with scientists and
the military coming
together saying let's weaponize this
virus as much as we can let's see how
deadly we can make it for absolutely no
reason at all let's finance
this research let's even let's make sure
it happens in wuhan
let's let's make sure we study this
crazy pathogen
and and let's bring them all together
let's be mad scientists let's create a
virus that could destroy the world why
why are we doing this why is this this
because why do they make nuclear weapons
there have been no scientific
breakthroughs that have actually worked
and have actually helped uh whether it
comes to science or modern medicine
through gain of function so
gain of function is testing like the the
danger of something
it's making it as dangerous as possible
for potential weaponized purposes
there have been no scientific findings
that have actually helped the scientific
community it's literally playing with
god
that's what the government playing with
god playing playing god sorry playing
god
and and thinking that you know you could
create something that could
essentially wipe us all out for for what
for what reason for war
exactly to defend against that like how
do you defend it
i would argue that the government's a
little bit too big and powerful and i
think we should step it back a little
bit
are you are you going to ignore china of
course i'm not going to ignore so sorry
i've been talking about china for very
long yes yes yes listen um
this is this is the the very serious and
inherent problem with
coming up and pulling out all the worst
possible things the united states has
done
because if you pulled up a list of say
all the worst possible things china has
done you'd be like wow i really trust
the americans gain a function
studies have been done in part
participation yes with the united states
yes and china
in wuhan and china was smuggling in
viruses and they got caught by the state
department yes and bill barr mike pompeo
they've been talking about this there
have been many arrests the point is
look man like i said there's two kinds
of people some people will look at
everything the united states has ever
done and say
don't trust the government and they
don't have a view out
many of these people don't have you
outside of the united states and realize
that
there are other way way worse things the
point is what i'm saying is you've got
to find
reasonable balance you don't want to
blindly trust anybody
you don't want to blindly trust the
government like the shirt you said
yesterday if you trust the government
you haven't learned from history
and they say those who who forget
history are doomed to repeat it
at the same time what if what we're
experiencing
is the other conspiracy that china
was was the one who manufactured
something like this and then the us is
desperately trying to defend us
and then you're actively opposing that
well the point is a very convenient line
that no no it's not convenient it's you
don't know we don't know
exactly because they're not honest and
they're not transparent and they're so
accountable this is why i say the best
thing you can do
is first i think everything they're
doing right now i find
uh uh what the gov what the government
is with the lockdown's completely wrong
yeah in terms of should we social
distance
yes i i don't have a big problem with
that we could deal with this
in a practical way that deals with the
elderly that deals with
making a vaccine i don't high five tim
anymore let's listen
let's not even know no more high fives
that's the worst listen listen they're
not coming out and giving you the
vaccine
you can't actually get i don't know that
yet no we do see what's happening in
canada you see what you've seen the the
chief medical officer in ontario just
announced that if someone refuses to
take the vaccine
the covid19 vaccine they won't have
freedom to move
around that's what i'm saying today by a
official government
that has disarmed their i am not a fan
of mandated
medication by anybody i am not a fan of
mass all the massive corporations just
going along with that and if you think
democrats won't force it on you
if you think como and other crazy
individuals that are already robbing you
blind won't do it on you
it's not it's a little bit naive let me
be honest here you think the government
can actually pass a law
the government is already in an insane
level where they are telling people when
they could leave their house
their the government is already telling
people that they can't drive their car
by themselves that's an issue they're
telling their people that they can't
even
have a paddleboard in the middle of the
ocean by themselves
that's what the government is enforcing
right now police who are breaking theirs
of the constitution but that's because
of politicians telling them how to do so
and it we already reached the insane
level we already reached a crazy level
and if you think it's going to subside
from here with all the power that was
granted to these psychopaths
mostly psychopaths i mean it's it's not
going to happen the issue in power
they love it they want more of it all
this comes down to
is that we have a growing escalation
between
china yes chinese infiltration the
democrats who are clearly breaking their
own rules and don't even believe
their own rules the world economic forum
and this election
and this is the point i'm making about
the explosive potter camp we're sitting
on
because you can talk about all this
stuff and you know why it's so
frustrating
you have no answer to any of this i do
know what's what's your answer make
memes
uh make your europe start your own farm
that won't change anything
when you come out where you come out and
say bye when you come out and say no to
the us government
and then open the door to china it
depends no no you don't have to open the
door to china
you don't have to you don't have to you
have to be aware of both of these issues
you have to be aware of china on the
geopolitical world stage and how they
want to be the predominant world power
that is a big threat
i have acknowledged it we have talked
about it extensively i 100 agree so what
do you do here in the united states to
deal with that
though you've been living this what have
you what are you doing right now no no
what do you do right now
i'm self-sufficient right as i've had
you learn how to farm you learn how to
defend yourself you learn how to use
firearms which i've been doing at
extreme levels this entire year you
learn how to defend yourself and to live
outside of any government control
any government influence how will that
allow
a cohesive strategic response to what
we're seeing from china well we're not
going to have a cohesive response right
now with the
presidency that i agree i know they what
we agree completely agree i believe
biden is the capitulation to china i
think what the democrats are doing is
detestable because they're clearly not
following their own lockdown rules
so the issue is how do we actually deal
with it
when instead if listen yeah no there's
there's there's no
good answer other than the keg is going
to explode
and everybody has a different opinion on
what they think must be done
so right now people what do you think
must be done i i agree with you on the
self-sufficiency part
buying the ammo learning how to how to
take care of yourself
being responsible for yourself and i've
i've often felt that way for the most
for most part of my life right now we
are in we're entering a period where
i've repeatedly said
and quoting a ton of other people we are
we are either off the cliff in terms of
polarization
the ceo of axios that the united states
is decoupling it is it is to the point
where
you bring this stuff with a stuff up
with a vaccine first and foremost
you can mention swine flu stuff i can
pull this up i totally recognize all of
this
but i think most people are going to be
completely fine
because they're rolling it out through
the elderly first the medic the people
who've gotten the placebos
then the medical workers than uh the
most vulnerable people who are at risk
of dying either way
yes but we have to understand there's
another conundrum here that a lot of
people aren't realizing
what's happening in china china right
now is fine
totally fine unaffected by this so
getting out of china is from the chinese
government so
well at the same time we're getting
images of thousands of people without a
mask
of the muslim camps yeah but we get
footage out of china but what what
happened
what's going on in africa africa is not
being as devastated by the sickness as
the worst of the world there's there's
something that
absolutely just doesn't make sense
that's not that's not necessary no
they're not sugar indoctrinated that's
not necessarily true
no one is going there and tracking any
of this there's no great big hospitals
writing all the numbers down
now i did a segment on the john hopkins
university newsletter
that said this this reporter her name is
doctor i believe brienne
that when she looked at the
year-over-year data she doesn't see a
major spike and
said she believed that heart disease
deaths were down and covadas were up
leading to what she believed was an
over-exaggeration
but still a lot of people will
look the reason why this is so
frustrating is that
everybody makes the leap of assumption
they say
if we're not hearing about africa that's
it and then there's no consideration as
to why that might be
so people are saying they deleted this
letter that proves they're censoring
hiding it
uh we're not getting data out of africa
that proves it it's not real or
china or like you mentioned china could
be lying they could be welding people's
doors
apparently nothing's going on or it
could be that the democrats
are overreacting refuse to accept
responsibility and are exploiting this
for political gain
they wanted an excuse for no you know
excuse mail in voting
they got it there's a million and one
reasons it is so difficult to break down
first and foremost the most important
thing you can do is be self-sufficient
rely on yourself take care of yourself
and do simple things to keep yourself
safe that are within certain reasonable
boundaries
social distancing wearing a mask is
totally reasonable like nationwide
lockdowns and statewide stay home orders
completely unreasonable destroying
everything i think i think it's
legitimate to start the conversation and
ask
those questions and to see wait what's
going on in africa what's going on in
china
because we are seeing a very unorthodox
situation where i think we should
question everything where i think we
should always be asking accountability
but asking accountability
from our government is not the same as
letting china win
you know we're not letting china win by
holding our government accountable or to
a higher standard
america wins when america is strong
honest
and and has its people in the know of
exactly what's going on because when the
people know what's going on
we're able to prepare and we're able to
make
moves in our lives that makes us safe
in the future rather than completely
unsafe completely unprepared and i was
gonna
family friendly show here i'm not gonna
say the
well-informed population is a
decentralized network will compute
correct answers more
uh more accurate than a single
individual who thinks they're smarter
and we're not informed
there's a lot of lies there's a lot of
bull crap no this it's it's also large
elements of the government it's also
large elements of the education system
it's also large elements of the
entertainment system
and the distraction bread and circus
system that we have to deal with and i
think
criticizing it is essential to making it
better not making china
win in some kind of circumstance or way
but i think us
standing up holding our government
accountable and saying you did this this
and this
make this right fix this tell us the
truth right now will lead
us towards a path towards of success
rather than capitulation towards china
and
so so what would satisfy you with the
pfizer vaccine
let's release all the data right now
about the trials
we're not getting any information
regarding the troubles that some
individuals are having
there's a lot of data that's absolutely
being hidden from the general public
about what happened during these studies
the exact
data the numbers the the details i want
to know all of it and i think we should
know all of it exactly what's happening
but we're being told
complications there's some complications
with some people what what is the
complication
i want liability for some of these
companies i want to make sure that
there's some
way if they egregiously go overboard and
abuse their power like they have before
that there is some kind of system where
there could be some retribution
for a horrible act now i'm saying they
still need legal protection
they still need to be protected in a way
because if if they face too much
liability they won't be able to do
anything but there's a middle ground
towards being egregious towards hurting
people and knowing you're going to hurt
people right
there's a there's a middle question go
ahead should people get the vaccine
um again
everyone has their own life and they
should educate themselves
about this about this issue and make
their own decision for themselves
uh i'm not in a place to tell people
what to do
i wouldn't be telling people what to do
i would tell people to do their research
do their homework
and when the data comes out and
hopefully we find out exactly what's
happening during these trials which
we're not right now
then i think we can make a better
decision but until that happens
uh until tell me what you're thinking
about tell me some good news about the
vaccine
i don't know uh i mean they're they're
talking about how this is a first
of its kind that has never existed that
will
essentially trick your body into
thinking that this has and if they're
in it okay let's play devil's advocate
here if this is an incredible medical
breakthrough
if this is something that helps people i
will be the first one to say
after the data comes out that this is
something that's
that's good but so right now but there's
a possibility there's a possibility for
either way yes
tons of public information saying it's
good very little saying it's bad
you've chosen the negative side of
things now i've chosen to look at
history
as an example of what could potentially
happen and i've chosen to understand
that
either outcome could happen and i'm
telling people do the research before
making that very important decision for
yourself
what do you research what do you read
what you mean
like to figure out i feel like i'm being
interrogated right now you know what you
are you because i'll tell you this
where's the bible
in my hands hold up on your phone
because
the issue i see is yes you can tell me
every negative thing in the world but
you can't tell me anything that's
positive you can't well no i just told
you in this in this
podcast i told you that there have been
medical breakthroughs by big pharma
that have had a substantial amazing
effect on individuals dealing
with these issues that's never no no no
no i mentioned both
no no i mentioned both i mentioned that
there have been amazing incredible
findings by
big pharma that would have never
happened if it wasn't for them that have
helped a large number of people
have there been also abuse abuses with
the opioid epidemic
hell yes but the only way to provo to
prevent so
what could someone research to make sure
they're making the right choice
um that's a very good question i would
look at
the first official line of version of
events
that the government says let's see what
they say let's see what
pfizer says let's see the claims that
they're making here
now let's test it on the backdrop of
people who criticize them people who are
the most vocal about it and then you
have two sets of data
and then you're going to make up your
mind whether you like this one or that
one
based off experience based off time
based off events that unfold i had
someone email me
telling me that there's a secret war
going on in frankfurt over security
servers yes
dominion voting machines and when they
do research that's what they find
well exactly the problem is the problem
is people choose
who and what they trust exactly there's
no denying i'm not denying that
so ultimately what it comes down to is
talk to your doctor and if you don't
trust your doctor well then you got to
find out
my ultimate question is to use reason
logic and multiple sources multiple
doctors
have you ever gotten a vaccine um
i'm not sure because when i came to this
country as
as as an immigrant i'm not sure if i got
vaccinated or not i think i i i listen
to this i got tested for my vaccines i
had my blood drawn and they said that i
have no
kind of i understand i understand
everybody was a little kid
the concerns over the speed at which the
vaccine is being put out are shared by
democrats
like i mentioned before it's you know i
think it was like biden kamala and cuomo
were all like i'm not going to trust
this thing i'm going to wait a little
while
and then there was a bunch of stories
that came out through like cnn saying
when polls come out most people like
a little bit less than half say they're
willing to wait 40 of medical
professionals are saying that they're
going to wait as well
right and i think so i'm bringing that
to logical thing to do to be to be fair
the other issue i have is i received
when i mentioned this before when i
traveled like five
vaccines in one day and as far as i can
tell
maybe something happened i don't know
maybe it made me really smart and
successful with youtube i have so much
spiderman i seem to be fine
healthy strapping young lad feel great
feel great uh life's good and the issue
is
recognizing the speed at which this
one's being brought out and the shared
the bipartisan concerns over the rate at
which it was produced that's a normal
thing people have
it's like should i not have trusted
going to the doctor the last time
when the doctor says this is what we're
going to do trust me no one says i
didn't say that
what do you mean there's a lot of people
who say that yeah like there's tons of
those
people crazy stuff right of course but
even if you look at
you know vaxxed their position wasn't
all vaccines are bad
it was some of them are rushed some of
them should be done at a longer interval
some of them should
wait especially if babies are receiving
them and it was
acknowledged that some vaccines are
actually good for you
i think i don't know if you watched vax
but but there was an element of that
that i think is
you know important to look at and to
examine yourself what an individual what
i've learned about older the older
vaccines not this one which is an rna
vaccine apparently they don't put the
virus in it
they give you something new which so
research rna vaccines and find out um
but the old vaccines what they do is
they take blood and then they filter the
virus into the blood
but they could only make the filter so
small because they had to let the virus
through
so other things that were the same size
as the virus or smaller would get
through the filter
and sometimes you'd get tainted vaccines
as a result
this is not so you're saying this
improvement could help contaminants and
things like that maybe
i'm not saying you know i want to i want
to shill
for pfizer i think what my my
what i think about this is i don't my
immediate personal bias and assumption
is that it's not a great breakthrough
it's them pulling out the old vaccine
and being like we could easily crank
something up for
a chronovirus we're gonna make so much
money off these dumb people the
governments are gonna transfer all their
wealth right into our pockets
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you